then there's apparitions that are
actually interactive I'm not just
talking about you see a ghost somewhere
but I'm talking about something that
appears to be conscious that doesn't
have a body that's actually responsive
to uh a human the action of a human
being like if you wave to it it waves
back something like that which you know
you're seeing this ghostly form and it
it responds to you and that suggests
that there's actual Consciousness there
and then you can pick up there's one
case in my book where you were able
actually this this young boy was able to
actually pick up messages from that
entity which was in their house and
everybody in the family was seeing it
and the entity revealed enough
information about herself that they were
La able to confirm that she was the
person who had previously lived in the
house and nobody knew anything about her
when they moved in so you know that's a
very strong case of an apparition that's
evidential it's not just the same as
somebody saying oh I was in a haunted
house and I saw a ghost